- [Mark] So Ruby.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Ruby. Why don't
we take off the hat?
- Yes, sir.
(laughs)
- [Mark] OK, Ruby.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Ruby, where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- Orange County, California.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You grew up with both your parents?
- Yeah, I grew up with both of my parents.
One was a foster and one was a regular.
- [Mark] So...
- Not foster.
My dad, married my mom.
- [Mark] Stepdad.
My stepdad. Yes.
- [Mark] Mom and stepdad?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- Excellent.
- [Mark] It was good?
- Yes.
- [Mark] What kind of kid
were you in high school?
- At high school, I played sports
and I did a lot of academics.
I graduated six months
early before my class.
- [Mark] You're a good student.
Yes, sir.
- [Mark] And then where,
where'd your life go after, after school?
- After school,
I have friends
and, um,
they took me to a whole
nother place in life.
I met the spaceship man (mumbles).
And my dad, he's Mexican mafia.
So, um, yeah
he brought me a lot of
wonders in the world.
- [Mark] He brought a lot of what?
- A lot of wonders in the world.
- [Mark] After high
school, you went where?
- After high school
I went to Apple Valley, California.
After high school, we stayed probably
about five years after that,
And then, I was from
Westminster, California
and my grandma,
she knew the people that owned
all the Edwards theaters.
So I'd be over there too.
I'm in Newport Beach, LA.
So that's, those are the two places I grew
up.
- [Mark] Okay. And how long
have you been down here,
on skid row?
- About two months...three months.
- [Mark] You're brand new.
Right now, I'm, uh,
It's just saving the world right now.
- [Mark] You're saving the world?
Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Um...
- I mean, opening keys that
I never knew I had the ability to
but when I had the ability
and God gave me that gift,
then I started doing it.
And special intelligence.
And I'm a fan- a federal judge as well.
- [Mark] You are?
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] What's your,
what's your drug, Ruby?
- I, I, I do whatever everybody else does
- [Mark] (laughing)
Well, that's everything.
- Well, that's just whatever,
I don't do heroin.
- [Mark] You don't do heroin?
- No, sir.
- [Mark] Got it. And
what do you do for money?
- Well, my husband collects
my welfare check right now.
Not my welfare, my, my,
I lived in the hospital
when I was a child - all my life.
I stayed in St. Joseph hospital.
CHOC. Children's Hospital of Orange...
- [Mark] So, you weren't with your family?
- [Ruby] A lot. Yes, I was.
My family, they'd come in and out
but I was like five years old
and I was always in -
living in the hospital.
- [Mark] Why is that?
- [Ruby] Because I had asthma.
Chronic, chronic asthma, where
I almost died like two times.
- [Mark] Wow.
- [Ruby] Yes, severe asthma all the time
I was in the living at the hospital.
So I'd be in and out of school.
Was raised with real good family.
So then I moved to
Apple Valley, California
and I married my, um
I divorced my husband.
Legally separated because
he's very abusive.
He sleep, uh, cheating on me
with other women downstairs,
so I had to get rid of him.
And so then I lived with
my mother in the backyard.
Well, one day the police,
they came, they arrested me
for throwing a pumpkin
at my dad and my stepdad.
And my mother was very sick.
She (mumbles) her mouth was open.
They said she had cancer.
Well, now that I found out my
husband was putting heroin.
He was pumping heroin in
to keep us sedated alone.
But I didn't know this at the time.
And when I left there, they
said my mother was gone
that she had died.
I don't believe that.
Cause I seen her after that.
In a Uhaul truck about
a year and a half ago.
And, um, my children, they
went into foster care.
- [Mark] How many children do you have?
- I have five.
- [Mark] Did you, did you raise them?
- Yes. As much as I did,
- [Mark] And they were...
- They were five.
And my other one was of age.
And I have a 13 year old right now.
So, um,
they told me that she died
and she didn't.
So,
I believe that the people of America
are taking care of her underground.
Cause I left a lot of people
underneath these, these floors.
I've probably already let over
a trillion people out, I'd say.
Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Where do you
sleep at night, Ruby?
- I sleep out just anywhere.
- [Mark] Just on the street?
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] No tent or anything like that?
- Huh?
- [Mark] No tent or anything like that.
- I'm sorry.
- [Mark] No tent?
- No. I sleep in different tents, stuff.
Just whatever happens, happens.
- [Mark] Have you ever been treated
for mental illness or anything like that?
- I don't have a mental illness.
- [Mark] You don't?
- No.
I live a very hard life,
but I'm the target.
- [Mark] You're what?
I'm the target.
- [Mark] You're the target?
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Of who?
- Of rat playing games,
snake playing games,
spaceship, monsters,
(laughs)
stuff like that.
But I'm okay, and I'm alive
thanks to Jesus Christ.
- [Mark] Is there one particular
drug that you lean on more?
It doesn't matter if I do.
I'm clear minded. I
understand what's going on.
I feel it. I live it. I breathe it.
- [Mark] Alright. Well, Ruby,
thank you for talking to me.
- Thank you, brother.
- [Mark] It's very interesting.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Good luck out there.
- God bless you. Thank you.
(traffic passing)